so take trade as an example they want to
have free trade and of course they can
do it on their own they can do it
unilaterally but they don't get the full
benefit if other countries aren't doing
the same they don't have they want to
see reciprocity and so they often use
international law as a way to entrench
that kind of reciprocity make it make it
so that the rules are clear everybody
understands this country's resists
international law for also for a whole
set of reasons the most common is
probably the idea that there are things
that are within our domestic domain we
usually talk about it in terms of
sovereignty so on the political right in
this country we often see resistance to
certain I mentioned the law of the sea
before as an example this is a treaty
that the Navy wants to see us enter into
there's a law of the sea Convention but
the resistance in the Senate is is based
on this idea that it's impinging upon
our sovereignty our right to do what we
want to do and that resistance is very
powerful in certain areas so for a long
time human rights treaties were not
ratified by the United States because
there was a fear that that was a
backdoor way to get out the south and
the South's treatment of
african-americans and that would be
another way for the federal government
to gain power against the states and for
these kind of nefarious international
types to start to control the u.s. so
that that theme runs through a lot of
the resistance to international law
oh definitely definitely it's still
there
and I don't mean to denigrate it because
I think there are areas where where
there's something to it right so we so
on the left you tend to see people
resisting free trade agreements
typically NAFTA right now has been a big
issue on the campaign trail and there's
a concern that was we enter into these
free trade agreements well what we're
really doing is we're selling out the
working person and and we're helping big
capital or or these kind of
transnational firms these multinational
firms and that we shouldn't give up the
right to control our environmental laws
or labor laws and so forth so so you see
the theme on the Left you see it on the
right the right is interested in other
issues climate change you know the
International Criminal Court but but
both sides have this concern and it's a
very legitimate one the balance the real
question is the balance between what
ought to be at the international level
what ought to be at the national level
would ought to be at the state level
hi I would be really surprised if we
went and renegotiated it I you know I
don't think NAFTA's neither the greatest
agreement ever nor a disaster it's kind
of actually for the u.s. a fairly
trivial in economic terms fairly trivial
agreement so I would be surprised if we
really renegotiated it and in fact you
know there's resistance to NAFTA in
Mexico and Canada nobody nobody seems to
really love NAFTA but I think a lot of
it is is is campaign driven I imagine
it's really hard to undo one of these
big treaties it can be done but it's not
easy